No,
you get these stories now.
And then about these companies that come out with claims that their brain
exercises can improve Iq and the literature on that is damn dismal.
I can tell you it's that the holy grail is to produce cognitive exercises that
produce a legitimate impact on fluid intelligence and,
and like there's been a lot of work done on that and the answer is so far is
that it doesn't work.
So what about the game?
What about the video gay bank?
I mean,
I know there has been a suggestion that played video games actually improves at
least sub aspects of intelligence.
There's a couple of studies that indicated that video games might improve
spatial intelligence,
but,
but
the problem,
and I think this is this is a critical problem or apps and insoluble one,
or at least no one's solved it,
is that what you get is that if you,
if you exercise yourself substantially on a given game,
you can radically accelerate your performance in the game.
So you can get much better at those specific skill share.
But you don't get generalization across cognitive sets,
which is what you're really hoping for it because I thought,
I thought that was the claim from some of these.
They have shown some increases in spatial Iq,
but there's not very many studies and I would say they're far overbalanced by
the other side of the research equation,
which continually says,
and I've looked at this because I'm really interested in the improvement of Iq.
I mean that's,
that's the holy grail in some sense.
And that,
and,
and uh,
the,
the overwhelming preponderance of evidence suggests that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow domain.
Now why that is,
and even this,
it's even worse.
Hey,
because you might say,
well,
imagine that you could take five different domains of intelligence still
associated type with g and you had people practice routines in all five
dimensions.
Maybe you'd get generalization under those circumstances.
And the,
the,
the results of the research attempting that indicate that no,
as soon as you move away from those specific practice instances,
you don't get generalization.
So I guess it's,
I guess it's subways.
Some of this is to be expected from the consideration that everything is an
allocation problem with it within the body at Bray into um,
that,
you know,
by a large
an improvement blood domain tends to be bought at the expense of something else.
Uh,
yeah,
just that.
Right.
And then conscientiousness,
I can tell you some research we've done.
That's cool.
Although we haven't been able to demonstrate that it's actually improved.
Conscientiousness,
the first thing to note about conscientiousness is that no one understands it at
all,
especially the industriousness element.
There's no plausible biological,
psychological neurophysiological or animal models for conscientiousness.
All we've got is self reports.
We can't even find tasks that conscientious people do better.
It's unbelievable.
But um,
blue self reports really awesome.
Well you can get reports from teachers and parents and so forth,
but it's all human report.
She only way we can measure it and we didn't know.
Like in my lab we probably tried 200 tasks trying to find something that
conscientiousness,
conscientious people do better.
No luck.
We can derive it from linguistic analysis of verbal output now to some degree.
But that's still,
that's not a task,
you know.
So now we,
we produced a series of programs called the self authoring suite and one of
them,
the future authoring program to writing program that helps people lay out their
plans for the future in,
in detail.
So they have to consider their,
um,
their intimate relationships,
their career goals,
their educational goals,
their use of time outside work,
their plans to maintain mental and physical health or their use of drugs and
alcohol.
They have to write for 15 minutes about what kind of life they'd like to have if
they were taking care of themselves three to five years in the future.
And then to write for the same amount of time about how terrible their life
could be if all their bad habits took control.
Okay.
And then they have to turn the pause division into an implementable plan.
And we've managed to improve their college grades by about 20% and dropout there
drug dropped their dropout rate by about 25% over about 10,000 students now.
But you know,
we tried to see if that was mediated by an improvement and conscientiousness and
there was no evidence for that.
Now what it was mediated by was number of words written during the exercise.
So it turns out that thinking more about your future helps,
the more you think about it,
the more it helps.
And maybe that,
you know,
maybe that would translate into an improvement in conscientiousness across time.
But um,
there haven't been any credible studies that I know of indicating that there are
exercises that can be done to improve conscientiousness.
So that's also,
you know,
troublesome and worrisome because that would be a nice thing to be able to do
content.
I mean,
I haven't thought much about it and I don't know much about the literature and
cut yet just this as a trait.
But the word seems to connote to me as an ordinary English speaker has a strong
social element to it as well.
It's kind of like a country yet just person is somebody who doesn't forget his
obligations.
Your index of conscientiousness and a university professor is,
you know,
somebody has asked you to write them a reference letter for getting into
graduate school or whatever.
Do you actually prioritize and get the Dab to think dotted Tibor is there some
risks that you'll just forget about it and shove it to them somewhere else?
Um,
I imagine cut,
she had just,
this is having a strong element of,
of attentiveness to social obligation and to the wellbeing of others as it is
defined in the personality.
Literature doesn't have any of that.
Well
I would,
I would say not so much attention to the wellbeing of others because that's more
trait agreeableness.
Okay.
That's more than maternal dimension.
But there's definitely a massive effect of social obligation,
which is part of the reason why conservatives tend to be hired
conscientiousness,
the liberals,
but it's not well being of others.
It's duty.
And so the,
the,
the conscientious types may form and maintain social contracts.
Yes.
They implement their plans.
Yup.
And they seem to feel shame and self contempt when they,
when they fail to live up to their social obligations.
And so that's another thing that's interesting about the income redistribution
idea because it's conceivable to me that conscientious people would hate that
because conscientious people do very badly.
For example,
if they're on,
if they're laid off from work,
even if it's not their fault,
they still take themselves apart for their failure.
So and so conscientious people in particular seem to find in activity without
productivity,
highly aversive and adverse if enough to really cause them in all major health
problems.
So
yeah,
that could,
that brings us back to what we were discussing a little while ago,
the problem of
hub,
ensuring that large numbers people have access to BD goof all work in an age at
which it is more and more the case that uh,
the big components of the economy of our Blue Bay got away with very few
employees.
I don't know.
I that's going to continue.
That's probably going to ask away or back to that same topic to some extent.
Yes.
But again,
I,
I mean I think,
I think any inequality of opportunity is sort of the bottom are bedrock of any
quality.
Yeah.
Having its impacts upon us.
It's,
it's certainly the bond,
but bedrock of,
of
why we should care about it.
Odd moral and social justice.
Grouts it's like,
well why should people who,
okay,
why should [inaudible] birthright affect the opportunity is available to what
and
well,
it's also with social catastrophe because hypothetically you want to set up a
society so that whatever someone has to offer is maximally offerable to the
community because otherwise the community loses.
Yes.
Now it seems to be,
I mean,
I think one of the great examples of that,
although I don't think this accounts for all of it,
is that the relationship between the provision of women's rights by countries
and their economic productivity is staggeringly high.
So I think that also has to do with o openness in general to transformation and
change with,
with,
with the provision of women's rights being an index of that.
But nonetheless,
it's a great predictor of the eventual economic success.
Well,
partly it had ducks and partly perhaps bar more direct effect that after all,
it slightly over half the population,
um,
maybe their talents are better utilized.
Um,
that's certainly what we would hope.
And I think,
I think,
as you said,
I think the evidence at least suggests that.
So,
okay,
so let me recapitulate,
because we should probably fold this up.
And so,
so.